the final season of Game of Thrones has
arrived but before we can get to the
ending first we have to understand the
beginning we've got the whole history of
Westeros mapped out for you just in time
to get ready to see it all come crashing
down here's the entire game of Thrones
timeline explained in the distant past
Westeros was the home of the children of
the forest but roughly twelve thousand
years before the first episode of the
series takes place the first humans
arrived from across the sea the children
of the forest called them the first men
and two thousand years of war and soot
finally a truce was called but it was
too late the children turned to dark
magic to protect themselves and
inadvertently created the undead Knight
King and his White Walkers once the pact
was signed around 10,000 BC the first
men entered the Age of Heroes with
legendary figures like bran the Builder
and land the clever creating much of
what defines Westeros as we know it but
the Age of Heroes is defined most by the
long night around the Year 8,000 BC the
White Walkers broke free from the
control of the children of the forest
bringing about a winter a perpetual
night that lasted an entire generation
in that darkness the White Walkers came
for the first time they swept through
cities and kingdoms riding their dead
horses the children and first men banded
together to defeat the night king but at
great cost
the children were nearly driven to
extinction and the wall was built to
keep the walkers trapped in the frozen
north along with the tribes of humanity
who would become the wildlings our
clearest glimpse of this era comes from
the season 7 episode the spoils of war
in which Jon Snow and Daenerys examine
cave paintings beneath Dragonstone of
the walkers the children and the first
men starting around 6,000 years in the
stories passed a new group of human
invaders arrived the Andals originally
from Essos the Andals were compelled by
visions of a seven faced God to cross
the sea and settle Westeros their
religion which became the faith of the
seven spurred social developments like
knighthood and chivalry the first men
pushed out by the waves of Andals
arriving over the course of several
thousand years slowly retreated to the
north where their traditions were kept
by families like the Starks and the
Mormo
still two people from Essos anyone from
Westeros is considered to be an Andale
which is why even north men like Jorah
are given that nickname by those who
don't know any better
where are the Dragons we betray her
again Jorah the Andal speaking of Essos
that continent developed very
differently than Westeros thanks to the
magicians and Dragon Riders of legendary
Valyria they developed the dragon view
stone roads which still crisscross esos
and invented Valyrian steel the
strongest metal ever known but roughly
400 years before the events shown in
Game of Thrones all of that ended with
the doom of Valyria a cataclysmic
volcanic disaster that left the fabled
Empire in ruins
magnificent mmm looks fresh forged -
dude no one's made a Valyrian steel
sources of doom of Valyria among the
only survivors were a minor family
called the Targaryen who had left Essos
for the castle Dragonstone in Westeros
12 years earlier after a prophetic dream
warned them of the coming doom the
Targaryen 's were suddenly the survivors
of a lost culture and among the few
people in the world with dragons at
their beck and call though the forces of
the Targaryen were puny compared to the
Great Houses of the Seven Kingdoms
they held the trump card three great
dragons written by Aegon the Conqueror
and his two sister wives hey Gunn United
the Seven Kingdoms under his rule
creating the Iron Throne out of the
swords they surrendered to him in the
year 280 the seeds of the Targaryen
downfall were sown the Mad King Aerys
Targaryen decided to marry off his son
and heir the beloved Prince Rhaegar to
the Dornish princess Elia Martell the
sister of Prince Doran and Oberyn
Martell but Rhaegar secretly was in love
with Lyanna Stark the betrothed of
Robert Baratheon in the year 281 Prince
Rhaegar won a tournament at Harrenhal
but instead of naming his wife as the
tournament's queen of love and beauty he
chose lianna driving a wedge between
house Baratheon and the Targaryen x' and
they weren't alone breaking tradition
the Mad King named Tywin Lannister's son
Jaime Lannister as one of his Kingsguard
forcing Jaime to renounce his claim as
heir to House Lannister Tywin was
enraged and resigned as the hand of the
king retreating to
surely rock that set the stage for
everything that has happened in the show
since in the year 282 Rhaegar had his
marriage annulled and secretly Wed Liana
the starts though believing Liana was
captured against her will protested to
the Mad King in a fit of rage the King
murdered Lord Rickard and his eldest son
Brandon Stark Brandon's brother Ned
joined with Robert Baratheon and
rebellion your father and brother rode
South once on a king's demand during
Robert's rebellion Rhaegar was killed by
Robert Baratheon but not before Liana
became pregnant Ned Stark found her on
her deathbed
having just given birth to a son she
named Aegon Targaryen ned secretly vowed
to raise him and protect him and did so
by adopting him as his own bastard son
whom he renamed Jon Snow meanwhile the
Mad King decided to destroy all of
King's Landing rather than surrender
leaving Jaime Lannister to kill him
earning the name Kingslayer the mad
Kings pregnant wife though escaped to
safety but tragically Prince Rhaegar
wife Elia Martell and their two children
weren't so lucky
murdered by the mountain at the orders
of Tywin Lannister I'm going to hear you
confess before you die you raped my
sister you murdered her you killed her
children with a Mad King slain and his
army thoroughly beaten Robert Baratheon
took the throne he married Cersei
Lannister though he never stopped
mourning Liana she belongs with me
Ned Stark returned home to Winterfell he
never told anyone the truth of John's
parentage letting even his own wife
believe he had betrayed her with another
woman embittering her forever against
John as for the mad Kings wife while she
died giving birth to a daughter named
Daenerys who along with her older
brother Viserys was smuggled across the
sea to Essos in the hope that one day
they could return to Westeros to claim
their throne by winning the game of
Thrones check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Game of Thrones are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]